I'm Pete Cashmore CEO and founder of
Nashville and we have to answer some
questions from dabis from YouTube users
is one from the nuke how you integrating
technology to enhance value create
capsule and create collaboration within
your corporate structure so vegetable is
a media company and what we do is cover
all the cool stuff that's happening in
social media and digital media so
YouTube Facebook what Google's up to on
Google class every social network
Twitter how to use them for your life
how to make your life better using those
networks and the way that we integrate
social and technology into our
organization is at every level so
everyone a magical has social media
accounts they share everything they're
doing they use it to source articles
from social media sites that people
might put out a Twitter message then
went out a YouTube video asking for
ideas for articles what people want to
know about next but i also think social
media can help corporations to be more
transparent and more honest everyone
makes mistakes but when people make
mistakes has been great examples of
people going for instance to youtube in
the case of dominos when those a bit
over an uprising with a bit of a scandal
there it's a great opportunity to be
honest to confront an issue and to
actually win people around as many
organizations have done including
dominoes in that case so I think it's a
real opportunity to speak directly to
your customers or to your users and it's
a great opportunity to be super
transparent to be human to say hey we
failed at this thing or here's what
we're thinking about what do you think
that and I think corporations have
struggled with them because they want to
look like they know what they're doing
all the time they're absolutely definite
and they're not human and I think
consumers are okay with people being
human and with corporations being more
more transparent and with their
employees being on social media and
talking about how excited they are in
her passionately or about the company so
as my answer to the nuke on YouTube and
thanks a lot for your question from
Davos
you